you
so I want to talk a little bit about how
data transformed my life so I'm going to
give a talk and then Ryan Adams who's
actually like a real scientist and
actually does like real math and work
and that kind of stuff he's going to
actually give like a fairly technical
talk my talk is going to be not that
technical at all or not technical at all
but hopefully entertaining but I'm
talking a little bit how data
transformed my life and how I believe
data scientists will one day rule the
world and I hope that one of those data
scientists that's going to rule the
world is here today because then I can
say I knew them when they were nothing
or just a member of the this meetup so
Who am I well how many of you guys have
seen 21 or read the book bringing down
the house so you'll know what i like to
call Hollywood magic and I mean true
Hollywood magic is how you turn an
average looking asian american male into
a dashing british white guy because
that's what they did in the movie i was
the inspiration for the main character
in the movie 21 it all started in 2001 a
friend of mine my name is ben mezrich
was a writer and he had written seven
novels but it's fair to say that his
career was pretty much in the at
that point he had business school
applications out and was contemplating
not being a writer anymore and I said to
him Ben I have a great idea for your
next book he says well what is it and I
said well me and my buddies from IT we
go to Vegas we win lots of money using
mouth to beat the casinos and this sort
of like glossy look went over his face
and he said you know what I don't think
anyone wants to read about a book about
a bunch of MIT nerds and I said okay and
then about three weeks later I said come
to Vegas with me and I took him out
there and I showed him what we did and
he goes oh my god this is the coolest
thing I got an idea and I said what he
goes we should write a book about this
and I was like great idea Ben and then
he went on to take me to meet his
publisher we pitched this idea and his
publisher said you know what great story
probably a great Wired magazine article
but not something anyone wants to read
no one wants to read a book about a
bunch of MIT nerds and so we didn't
listen to where we wrote the book
bringing down the house that was in New
York Times bestseller for over two years
and then a guy
the name of Kevin Spacey read the book
he liked it so much that he eventually
turned into a movie called 21 21 was
number one in the box office two weeks
in a row and made 150 million dollars
off a 35 million dollar budget so in the
end but somehow Hollywood accounting
said that it was a non-profitable movie
which is like amazing about Hollywood
accounting but I guess in the end people
did want to read a book and see a movie
about a bunch of MIT nerd so that was
cool because we won in the end and what
was interesting is that Ben went on to
write a book called the accidental
billionaires which got turned into a
movie called the social network which
won an Oscar and I can say and you know
Ben when won't made you know won an
Oscar but I can say I made Ben Mezrich
kuya's today so that's cool so I'm going
to talk to you guys about a few things
and like again this isn't going to be
hard science but I think some of these
lessons hopefully that I'm going to talk
to you guys about will be super valuable
to you in your career as data scientists
in your career working with data because
so much of being impactful with data and
being impactful and I do mean this
impactful in the world going forward is
not being able to build a better model
or you know creating a better algorithms
from someone else it's actually being
able to take that information and
communicate it and sell it and actually
help companies and help people make
decisions with that data so I'm going to
tell you some stories that may or may
not have great technical roots but it
will have hopefully great life lessons
or business lessons to them so my
defining moment that I always talked
about was when I was 21 years old and I
had just learned this blackjack system
okay and everything that we did every
decision that we made at the blackjack
tables was subject to something called
conditional probability meaning what you
see impacts what you're going to see
right blackjack is really the only game
in the casino that has that aspect to it
every other game like roulette you know
like all those other games they don't
like poker does to some degree but poker
as human interaction that actually makes
it more difficult but blackjack is this
closed system where what you see impacts
what you're going to see you can model
it perfectly I always like to say it was
big data before there was this even term
because
blackjack was simulated out millions of
times before you know people knew what
to do so every decision you make can be
governed by math so I walk up to a
blackjack table at Caesars Palace I'm
about six months into my blackjack
career every decision I make is
objective not subjective I walk into the
table when I bet two hands of ten
thousand dollars and on the first hand I
get a pair of nines on the second one I
get 11 and the dealer has a 5 up so how
many you guys play blackjack know what
I'm supposed to do here pair of nines
against a five what do i do I need a
split so I need put down another ten
thousand dollars and I get to play each
nine separately on the first night I get
a two to make 11 what do I need to do
double down so I do I put another ten
thousand dollars down and I get an 11 I
mean it sorry I get an 8th to make 19
and then on the next night I hit and I
get a jack to make 19 and the 11 against
the five what do i do I need to double
down again which means I put another ten
thousand dollars down all right and I
get another eight on that to make 19 so
I've 19 19 19 against the dealer's five
okay how much money do I have on the
table $50,000 thank God you guys got
that like when I speak a lot and tell
the story a lot and a lot those people
are like Oh 30 or 40 thousand dollars
when I spoke at the National accountants
Association and I was so excited I'm
like you guys of all people are gonna be
able to get this and they're all like
30,000 40,000 I was like there's no
why our countries in a deficit so anyway
so anyway he's got 18 eighteen nineteen
nineteen 19 against a dealer's five
dealer flips the six to make 11 and then
gets a king to make 21 I lose fifty
thousand dollars this one behind me
shrieks oh my god that's my entire
mortgage I want to turn around go where
the hell do you live is
where we live in San Francisco that's a
cardboard box in the Tenderloin so the
math and again like everything is
objective here the math now calls from
me to bet three hands of ten thousand
dollars and this is one of those moments
that you wonder like how did I get here
because certainly like the recency bias
of losing those hands makes me doubt
like the emotion makes me doubt and the
only way to get through something like
this is to be really data-driven but I
remember that this is one of those
moments that I sort of reflect on how I
got here so I graduated from MIT with in
nineteen nineteen ninety-four with a
mechanical engineering degree that I've
never used in my life it makes my
parents really happy I went on to work
in finance so back in those days kids
weren't going into startups they were
going into finance if they didn't want
to do engineering and I went and worked
on the chicago board options exchange
and then I started getting into the
whole internet thing and everything was
going on there I moved back to Boston
learned how to program and ended up
starting for different companies the
first one was a company that did golf
content instructional content and other
was a FinTech company that before
FinTech was actually even a term then I
did a sports media startup that we sold
the Yahoo this circle ending the FinTech
company we sold to Richard Branson a
virgin the golf company we sold to
demand media and then most recently I
started a company called 10x or and so
actually like I'm going to see how this
joke travel I like to talk about al gore
and obviously we all know the Al Gore
internet joke but you can say al gore's
invented two things one good one bad he
invented the internet which was good for
all of us we wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for him and then then a global
warming which has been bad for us though
usually it's hit or miss joke but I like
it anyway so we go back to this TEDx ER
that I started and this is kind of like
how I got into the whole world of data
the book Moneyball came out and I was
super excited about the idea of taking
what we did in the blackjack world and
trying to use it in the world of sports
and trying to Ashley
see if there were ways to make sort of
like every kind of decision data-driven
specifically around modeling human
behavior like human performance because
that's kind of what they were doing and
money ball and then 10 X or the company
I started we were trying to actually use
data to reinvent human capital
management or HR so the idea of it was
can you talk about or can you understand
someone by the data you pull out of
github or the data you pull out a giro
or the data you pull out of pivotal
tracker can that tell you something
about that person's work habits can that
tell you about how they're doing or how
they're trending and the simplest
example of this is imagine that you have
you know a median number of commits that
someone does each week and all of a
sudden you have a three standard
deviation event or two standard
deviation at one direction or the other
probably something is going on with that
person maybe they're just on vacation or
maybe they're you know struggling at
home but at least there's a small signal
there from the data so that was the goal
of 10x or we worked on it for a few
years we pitched the idea to be make
Twitter a customer of what we're doing
Twitter liked what we're doing so much
they said hey why don't you guys just
come build this here so we got acquired
by Twitter about a year ago and since
then i've been working at twitter
leading and working with some of the
smartest people I've ever worked with a
group called business insights that's
trying to drive data-driven decision
making all around Twitter and it's super
exciting I love it I love Twitter i love
this work environment and i love how
smart the people are that work here so
let's just go back and talk a little bit
about so some of like the lessons that
I've learned from my experiences of
blackjack then I'm going to talk a
little bit about you know what I think
makes both people and teams impactful
and data science and then we'll bring on
Ryan so the first thing I think is
really important about being data-driven
is this idea of overcoming cognitive
biases so those of you guys that have
seen 21 you know that I'm in the movie
right I play a dealer named Jeffrey the
guy that plays me walks up to me and
says my brother from another mother
Jeffrey like there's a funny but this is
ringing no bells to people is this
well if you want to go back and watch it
it's a bats at about 59 minutes and
three seconds so this wonderful scene
that none of you guys seem to remember
you know it took three days to film but
I always up have this up here it's kind
of like a funny reminder of being in the
movie but then to talk about one of the
most difficult decisions I ever made at
the blackjack table so those you guys
that play blackjack have you ever split
tens raise your hand if you've ever
split tens okay you guys are all welcome
in my casino in the future unless you're
really counting cards and you're good
card counter there's no reason to split
times but imagine that black jacket or
sort of card counting is tracking how
many tens face cards and aces remain in
the deck versus how many low cards and
imagine that you know almost every card
you haven't seen so every card remaining
is a ten a face card or an ace and you
have a pair of tens and the dealer has a
six showing at that point do you think
you should split tens maybe you have a
higher expected value right so look
splitting tens is something you learn
eventually as you progress in your
blackjack career and it's a little bit
more of an advanced skill so I rolled up
just learn this to a table at MGM grand
in las vegas but two hands of eight
thousand dollars and the dealer gives me
a block on the first one pair of times
on the second one the dealer has a six
up so I'm looking at this and I'm
scanning the cards on the table when I
go holy I'm supposed to split these
but the dealer pays my blackjack because
of me twelve thousand dollars and then
starts to go by my pair of tens because
what idiot is going to split tens with
eight thousand dollars on the table I
looked at her us in ma'am I think I want
to split these and she said you want to
what those and I said I think I want to
and as I looked her I'm like man I don't
really want to split these and I started
thinking about why that was and I
realized that as i looked around this
table as i looked around the people now
who are gathering around the table that
everyone there thinks i'm a if i
split these tens they think I'm an idiot
and if I do it's going to create a lot
of conflict like people are going to
like hate me they're going to yell at me
they're going to say I'm ruining
cards all this crap right there just
going to like make me like uncomfortable
okay but what's happening there I'm
falling for something called group thing
ok we're on being influenced I'm making
a decision based on avoiding conflict
and anytime you do that you're going to
make a bad decision and if you think
about our role as data scientists or as
data leaders and as people that are on
the cutting edge of technology you're
going to make decisions that they
wouldn't have made a year ago or two
years ago or three years ago so you are
going to make very unpopular decisions
all the time and if you're afraid of
conflict you're never going to be able
to innovate so overcoming group think is
an important part of innovation or
fostering innovation so I'm like all
right I don't give a what any of
these people say but I still don't want
to split these tens and I'm wondering
himself why do I still not want to split
those tens and I realize it's because I
have 20 I have eight thousand dollars
and in my mind I've already chopped up
in eight thousand dollar win but what am
i falling for their loss aversion right
I'm basically fearing a loss more than I
am the gain that I'm going to get from
that I'm making decision to avoid losing
and this is something that causes us to
make bad decisions all the time when I
first moved out to Silicon Valley in the
mid-2000s there was a company called
Apple that was trading for about 60 my
buddies and all were like Apple stock we
got to buy this we use the products it's
great well this is totally under price
11 months later and went to 120 and my
buddies where I like sell our Apple I
said why and they said well it just
doubled we don't want to be greedy do
you think apple is a buyer sell at 120
well we actually we kind of still think
it's a bi but we don't want to be greedy
we don't lose any of money we made that
decision to buy or sell apple should
have nothing to do with where you bought
it or ain't it should have to do with
where else you could put your money what
your other alternatives are you
shouldn't be worried about losing right
there's another company in the valley
that we don't like to talk about a
Twitter called fake
book I'm just kidding we love Facebook
and I've spoken twice at Facebook and
the second time I spoke at Facebook was
the day they announced the first time I
spoke there was they had 30 million
users the second time I spoke there was
the day they announced their 500 million
p user and when I was sitting there
talking to them I went through this
story and I said you guys are a perfect
example now that you are you know an
established company with 500 million
users are you going to take the same
kind of and before the words were even
out of my mouth an executive from the
back row named Tomas screamed hell yeah
and what he was saying is he knew that
for them to continue to grow they would
have to continue to take risks and I
think buying Instagram you know for a
billion dollars which doesn't seem like
a risk at all now but whatsapp for 19
billion oculus for 2 billion they've
been willing to take risks and that's
one of the reasons they've been so
successful so I can't fall for loss
aversion I got to go in and I got to
actually like make this decision I put
another eight thousand dollars down I
said I'm going to split these she gives
me an 11 and ace on one gives me a nine
on the other so I have 19 and 21 dealer
flips is six sorry flips a 10 to make 16
and then gets another 10 to make 26 I
win my sixteen thousand dollars I
grabbed the money walk away from the
table mostly because everyone at the
table now wants to kill me but making
that decision i think was an important
part and sort of like you know
understanding a loss aversion and
overcoming groupthink and hopefully
there's our two stories that you guys
can think about as you think about
making better decisions or explaining to
people you work with how to make better
decisions so let's talk about making an
impact with data science the first thing
i want to talk about and this sounds
stupid is that duh it starts with the
data okay and at twitter alright we can
play a law because our data is in places
that are difficult to get to and because
it requires a very challenging language
to get to it often and a lot of data
scientists don't come in here with great
knowledge of scalding so you've got to
you got to like take some real guts to
like start getting it and if you can't
get to the
data you're not going to answer any
questions but the reason that's true is
because twitter has so much data and so
if you can unlock that there's so much
value to that right so but everywhere
every time everything you do in data
science starts with data you know and
sometimes that data isn't clean
sometimes at times that data isn't even
collected and as simple as it sounds you
have to embrace the idea that like the
data the building blocks that's the
building blocks of how you're going to
be successful is data scientists getting
access to the best day let me give you
example this so how many guys are
football fans here and it fell fans okay
either there's not a lot of football
fans here or no one's really willing to
raise their hand but basically there is
like a movie that came out a while ago
called the blind side and there was a
book by a guy named Michael Lewis and
and what his the story was was
essentially that the often one of the
stories and themes in the book was
there's this position in football called
offensive left tackle that is the second
highest paid position in the league
behind quarterback okay and there's no
stats that tell you who's the best left
tackle in the league none like I could
ask people in this room like well how
would you judge it and everyone come up
with reason like like stats and they
would be completely flawed there was an
executive who was running a team at the
time who was a GSB graduate very
successful very analytical looked at
this and said I don't like this let's
let's figure this out so we went and
talked to people like coaches and scouts
and things like that and asked them what
do offensive left tackles do on every
play and what he ended up doing was
created like this decision tree where at
the end he had all these different
outcomes good and bad for what an
offensive tackle could do on any play
and then he hired coaches like paid them
in tickets like high school coaches to
sit and watch Game film and create
statistics about offensive tackles and
that's the same thing as like hiring a
bunch of people on Mechanical Turk to
like label hand labels some things like
getting to data or embracing the fact
that it all starts with data is the most
important part of you know the beginning
of getting
advantage in data science the second
thing that I think is really important
in a data science team or in any team is
this idea of trust right like when you
think about trust and like when I took
over the team here there were definitely
issues where people weren't ready to
work together and and you see this all
the time and what you have to understand
and when you especially when you are an
analytics person you're going to go into
situations where people don't trust you
because they don't trust the numbers or
they don't you have to get people to
trust you and the way you get people to
trust you is to make them understand
that you and them have the exact same
intentions you care about the same
things like you care like here the way
we do that is like everybody cares about
making Twitter successful and as long as
we all believe that we all care about
ultimately only one thing making Twitter
successful every conflict will work out
because people trust each other so
developing trust is another big issue
tackle the most impactful problems okay
and now this is like a challenging one
because like what I like to do with my
team is I like to allow them to sort of
pick what they work on right allow them
to tackle what I believe is to be the
most impactful problem and a lot of
times if you're a support function as a
data scientist people are telling you
what to work on and I don't think that's
right i think you should lead the charge
because you look at the data and you
know the macro problems you can figure
out what's the most impactful thing to
work on but the caveat with that is if
you do that you're going to have a
little bit of chaos all right and what i
mean by that is you're going to end up
working on things and then working on
another thing and working on another
thing and if you're good every one of
the company is going to want you to work
on something else so you have to
understand and be okay with that and a
lot of data scientists I know are not
okay with chaos right they want order
and they want things to be very defined
but you have to be okay with basically
trying to tackle the most impactful
problems you need partner with the right
stakeholders and this is really
important because when i think about
data science i think about the bottom
layer being data the second layer being
analysis and the third layer being
implementation and implementation can
either be you if you're good and you can
go out and you sell your ideas you can
go and be up
product manager or it can be a
stakeholder and the thing with the
stakeholders are they're going to know
they are going to be the ones that give
you a lot of value the ones that help
you understand whatever you're in
because they're in it every day when I
used to work in sports I started company
in sports and we wanted a really good
face of our basketball operation and so
we went to this guy Jerry West if any of
you guys have ever seen the NBA logo you
know who Jerry West is because the NBA
logo is his silhouette and I sat down
across from him in Memphis and he was a
GM in Memphis and he looked at me and he
said boy I got want me to tell you I
hate statistics and I was like
wow this is going to be great a great
half hour in Memphis it's about 120
degrees do you know where I could get
some barbecue and after about I don't
know half an hour together I learned
that he didn't really hate statistics he
hated the way that people use them in
basketball gated to pick way that and
this is a quote that the people thought
Allen Iverson was a good basketball
player even though he needed 30 shots to
score 30 points right he had a next
level understanding of analytics and
stats but he didn't know it and at the
end of the conversation with me he was
like you know what I think my scouts
should be tracking every deflection that
people make I'm gonna make them do that
and you know this idea that he was like
this amazing stakeholder that I could
partner with that new basketball better
than I could ever hope to I had to take
that time to work with him and make him
understand what analytics what really
was and what statistics really were so
selling or partnering with the right
stakeholders is so important being
practical and this is the hardest one I
think for a lot of us is that like you
know like we want to build the best
models or we want the highest precision
the highest recall like we want it to be
perfect right now I know if you guys
have heard of quote by Patton said said
something to the effect of like a
perfect plan a no in perfect plan
executed perfectly is better than a
perfect plan executed imperfectly right
there were much more complicated
blackjack systems than the one we did
but if you did them and you didn't
practice them totally perfectly you were
going to make mistakes so we knew we
could implement ours perfectly and
sometimes the best
models are not necessarily the most
complicated they're the they're going to
be ones that you know give you gain and
aren't necessarily you know sometimes it
might be impracticable do the best the
perfect most perfect model so be
practical and develop other skills and
what I mean by that is like as perton it
as it is to drive to the truth you also
need to be all cell what you're doing
and being able to explain and present
and sell and and work with people and
you know really make what we do what we
do should be complicated but should
sound simple the final thing is know
that you're not a support function and
the title of my talk you know the
subtitle was this idea that how data
science is going to rule the world and I
really really really don't believe that
data science and analytics should be a
support function of the company I
believe it should have a seat at the sea
level basically making the CEO make the
right decisions or even being the CEO
one day because who is better to make
decisions the people that have all the
data or the people that don't have all
the data so i really want to challenge
you guys with that one idea which is
like don't think of yourselves as a
support function think of yourself as
losers as decision leaders as people
that have all the weapons all the
ammunition to make the decisions okay so
finally I know you guys want to know
like what happened did you know like did
he I'm not gonna be able sleep tonight
unless you well the end of the story is
in my book called the house advantage
playing the odds win big in business you
get it on Amazon and thank you guys no
I'm just kidding I'll tell you the end
of the story so recap just lost $50,000
got this woman behind me screaming about
her house and the math now calls for me
to about three hands of ten thousand
dollars so i do i put three hands of ten
thousand dollars down and I know I can
do this because I believe in data I
believe in data-driven decision making
all these ideas that i told you about
like I believed at age 21 I really
believe this and so I bet 310,000 I get
nine on the first 119 on the second ace
4 on the third one
so on the nine against the six I got to
double down again so I put another ten
thousand dollars down i get a queen on
that to make 19 and i got 19 against the
six i stand that ace four against the
six soft 15 is actually another double
down hand against the six so i doubled
that down and i get a 4 on that to make
19 so again 19 19 19 against the dealer
six I have another fifty thousand
dollars on the table a chance to win
back everything I just lost or to lose
two of those woman's houses so again
like defining moment only time in my
life like how did I get here like the
only reason reason I'm here is because I
believe like religiously in data-driven
decision making so the dealer flips a
king to make 16 and they get 25 to make
21 so I lose another 50 thousand dollars
I am crushed I walk upstairs to my room
well I take an elevator upstairs to my
room at Caesar's Palace I collapse on
the floor stare up at the ceiling wonder
why there's a mirror on the ceiling I'm
21 I'm like why is there a mirror this
is so people lie in bed and get ready
that seems weird and once so once i get
over this tangent i started thinking
about what am I going to do next and I
think about it and I start thinking
about all these ideas about cognitive
biases and I started thinking about like
okay well if I don't play anymore I quit
this weekend maybe I'll start playing
again well that's subject to something
called omission bias right where I'd
rather make a bad decision by favoring
in action over action and then I think
about like well if I don't plan him
where I won't lose well that will be
being loss of Earth right which is what
we talked about like you can't be afraid
to lose if I don't play I'm not going to
win and I'm playing a positive expected
value game I know mathematically so not
playing is ultimately a bad decision and
then I started thinking about this whole
concept of you know results bias or
outcome bias so separating the decision
from the outcome had I made a good
decision and just suffered a poor
outcome or had I made a bad decision and
I was really sure that I made a good
decision just suffered a poor outcome
just gotten unlucky so
can't be results biased and finally I
started thinking about like holistically
the big picture and I think this is one
of the most important parts of
data-driven decision making you can't be
swayed by short-term results you have to
give yourself an opportunity to make
this decision millions of times or to
think about this decision in that way a
good example this is there's a guy Shane
Battier who played basketball in the NBA
and Shane played at Duke really smart
guy Michael Lewis also wrote an article
about Shane and Shane goes and speaks at
similar events I spoke speak out and we
were at an event one time and he was
talking about teaching LeBron James to
be decision to be data-driven and he was
talking about guarding Kevin Durant
because the stats say that when Kevin
Durant shoots over his right shoulder he
shot like sixty percent when he shouted
shoots over his left shoulder he shoots
forty percent so he told the Brawn like
hey just for this game I want you to
guard LeBron I want you guard Durant and
make him shoot over his right shoulder
right don't don't don't let him shoot
over his left shoulder I said you know
just just for this game and so he did it
Durant had a terrible game so LeBron was
like oh yeah this is this makes a lot of
sense this data makes a lot of sense now
what's the problem with that story right
is like what happens if this is an
outlier game where Durant I mean you're
only talking about maybe 20 shots right
where Durant just has a great game and
all sudden now that's going to make him
not data-driven so I would never put
myself in a situation where you know my
outcome is going to be based on or my
whatever ultimate outcome is only going
to be based on one or two trials and
hopefully you guys never will also so I
went back down and I kept playing and
actually I tell this story a law and
while I told the story one time at a
retreat that a VC legendary VC in the
valley vinod khosla was hosting and the
speaker before me that day was the guy
named Bill Gates and so when I walk up
there after Bill Gates I'm like this is
intimidating all right and as I'm
telling this story at the end of my talk
the node sitting in the front row who's
been on his blackberry the whole time
and I was amazed that he had a
blackberry first of all second of all I
didn't he was paying attention to me at
all and like he stood up as I got to the
story and he looked at me and he said I
don't believe you I said what do you
mean
I don't believe you how could you that's
what do you mean I said how could you
have doubted yourself how could you
doubted yourself and I realized that he
told me this he was right I didn't ever
really doubt myself and I you know I
really knew that I was going to go back
down and keep playing I went back down I
kept playing over the next two days I
won back the hundred thousand dollars
last day I was there I 170 thousand
dollars so i walked away up seventy
thousand dollars for the weekend and i
do think that that story is really like
how I got here today and how I've become
such a strong advocate for data-driven
decision making if I had walked away
when I wanted to I never would had a
movie made about me a book made about me
I never would have come been able to get
to meet all you guys here so hopefully
if you take away one thing it's this
idea and a lot of you guys hopefully our
entrepreneurs and hopefully are going to
stay in the valley and work hard but
when gets hard you got to trust
yourself you got to trust your method
you got to trust your process and
hopefully that's one thing you take away
from today so thank you guys